I'm really excited to be here with you this afternoon because the folks on this
panel,
such a wealth of experience and knowledge,
and I know they're going to,
uh,
give you tons of things to take away with you after you leave this afternoon.
Um,
I have the privilege of facilitating this panel.
and um,
yeah,
we're just going to dive straight in.
Um,
so let's start off with an easy question,
uh,
an introduction.
Tell us a little bit about yourself.
When did you do and what issue in your opinion,
is impacting Asians and Asian Americans that really matters to you right now?
So introductions and what issue that's impacting Asians and Asian Americans
that's really important and matters to you right now.
My name is Amy [inaudible].
I am a fiction writer.
I've written two works of fiction.
Um,
uh,
the first is a collection of stories called we should never meet,
which deals with um,
the,
uh,
there are eight stories based on surrounding the events of operation baby lift,
which was the emergency evacuation of admirations and Vietnamese orphans days
before the Vietnam War.
And my second book is a novel called the reeducation of Cherry job.
And it's about a multigenerational Vietnamese family living in both France and
America.
And so for both of those books,
and most of my work has been dealing with stories about people from the
Vietnamese diaspora.
So my books are often taught in college campuses and even high school,
high school campuses.
And the issues that often come up when I have these discussions with them is
about immigration and refugee experiences and how,
uh,
people migrate around the world and deal with the different social,
political and cultural communities that arise from history and what we can learn
from them.
And so I feel like that probably is the most important issue that pops up in a
lot of my readings and panels and discussion is how do we address the current
immigration and the ongoing immigration issues that are happening not only in
this country,
but around the world.
How do we help other people and other countries in need?
And I think,
um,
especially the Vietnamese community,
we have a lot to say about it.
And we,
uh,
especially since our community was the last major migration of refugees into
America.
Um,
we haven't had another recent one.
And I think that the Vietnamese American community can be seen as an example of
the incredible benefits and richness that can happen when you are generous and
when you're a compassionate and when you're exercising empathy,
which is I think something that's really important to consider when we're
thinking about a lot of raw there are being enacted and proposed right now.
Thank you.
Amen.
Um,
so my answer I think ties into that quite a bit,
but,
uh,
my name is [inaudible].
I'm a staff attorney meet immigrant rights program at the Asian Law Caucus,
uh,
age.
We'll talk us as a civil rights organization and San Francisco.
Uh,
we've been around since 1972.
My work is largely representing immigrants who are facing deportation.
Um,
and my client base is largely Southeast Asian refugees,
Vietnamese,
Cambodian,
Long.
While Yan refugees who came here in the seventies and eighties and are now
facing deportation,
uh,
largely for criminal convictions and experience is really common across a lot of
these refugee communities of resettlement.
In the u s where the resell and process was really flawed.
They were resettled in neighborhoods that had a really high rates of poverty,
high rates of unemployment,
high rates of incarceration at the height of the war on drugs.
And a lot of them were funneled into,
uh,
the present system,
the criminal system when they were teenagers and now decades later are facing
deportation.
Um,
and it's become a particular issue and problem as the Trump administration has
cracked down,
especially on Vietnamese and Cambodian communities,
uh,
with deportation rates.
Um,
and it's one of those issues which gets overlooked a lot and a lot of the
narratives around Asian experience.
Thank you.
Hi everybody.
My name's Russell.
Jen.
I'm chair of Asian American studies at San Francisco State,
um,
are celebrating our 50th anniversary of the Third World Strike and the founding
of Asian American Studies.
Um,
I've been living for the last three decades in a low income Asian American
community in Oakland.
And I'm there,
I think I see a lot of pressing issues facing low income and working class Asian
Americans.
And,
um,
if you talk about,
I think you're not supposed to talk about like an oppression Olympics,
but I do think that people living on the margin of living on the edge do face a
lot more struggle and suffering.
And so,
um,
I have a lot of unhoused neighbors who are Asian American.
I actually have students at San Francisco State are in Asian American Studies,
majoring in Asian American studies,
living in their cars,
um,
and some issues of class,
and the intersectionality with race and immigration and gender.
Um,
I think I really pressing for our times that a lot of the Asian American
community isn't aware of besides homelessness on a broader scale.
Um,
we're having mass displacement of Asian American communities could see China
towns being disappeared,
disappeared.
And you see a lot of gentrification and low income Asian American committee
aside.
I find that really significant.
Thank you.
Hi everyone.
My name is Mindy Chuang and I'm the former executive director now a board member
of collaboration and collaborations and nonprofit organization and a grassroots
movement to unify,
discover,
connect,
elevate,
Asian American Pacific islander artists.
So we deal with artists,
musicians,
dancers,
comedians,
filmmakers,
actors.
I'm also an actor now,
writer,
podcast host,
MC,
et cetera.
Mel multihyphenate millennial.
That is my representation on this candle.
And uh,
the most pressing issue that I'm interested in is definitely diversity in
Hollywood.
That is my entire universe,
especially Asian American representation.
I'm working and within and understanding the industry itself,
but also the implications that it has in the ripple effects of representation in
media,
in everything.
Everyone on this panel is talking about on immigration,
on politics,
on the economy,
in leadership roles,
in companies like Google,
um,
the bamboo ceiling,
everything.
There's such a wide diaspora of Asian Americans,
many of what most of wished,
you know,
99% of which never gets represented and is just beginning to have a voice in
mainstream media and what the dynamics of that are.
And now I'm working on writing films and shows so that I can contribute and,
and continue to talk in spaces like this to help make those connections.
So for me it's a understanding working in Hollywood,
also connecting that to other industries and other communities because this is
much larger of an issue and much larger strategies necessary.
How does diversity,
you know,
or if you want to use the intersectionality diaspora,
whatever your word is,
show up in your everyday life.
Um,
and how does this impact your work?
Well,
I was gonna say,
I think every Asian American,
actually every individual here will experience diversity in their families.
So I'm actually fifth,
sixth generation American.
My family has gone through,
you know,
exclusion,
segregation,
a lot of the racial barriers that a lot of people of color face.
But even within my own immediate family,
I'm married,
I'm Chinese.
Mary took Korean,
we have to foster daughters who were refugees from Burma.
And then my extended family are pretty multiracial.
And so I think everybody,
even if you're,
your family was of the same ethnicity and you know,
you have generational divides,
you'll have gender divides.
So every other than when we go out to eat and you're not,
you're not always eating Chinese food and rice every day.
So I think we all experienced diversity in our relationships and in our
histories and then just our day to day interactions with people at our workplace
or at our school.
So diversity is totally relevant in our,
in our circumstances and the u s
anybody else want jump in?
Did you want me to talk about that now or do you want me to like,
is there another question when you,
I know Mindy's nine to talk about
curious.
Well,
one of my examples of how I deal with diversity on my day to day life is that
there's a film coming out in August,
August 17th,
Fyi,
um,
called crazy rich Asians and uh,
John Chu who is from the Bay as am I,
um,
you know,
he's directing it.
It's an ensemble Asian American,
it's Asian.
It's actually a global Asian cast,
a half of whom were Asian American.
And that recognizing as a data point you will,
the fact that it's been joy luck club,
which was 25 years ago was the last like mainstream studio backed ensemble,
Modern Day Asian American family that was on screen is a big freaking deal that
it's been 25 years.
And the fact that there's the show like fresh off the boat and doctor Ken,
that there are these,
these blips on the radar about diverse representation of Asian Americans that
there so heavily weighted in terms of the gravity of like this is representing
all Asians when it's not.
I mean everyone here knows that they're more than 46 ethnicities and cultures
and length,
like way warm languages.
But uh,
you know,
the Asian includes so many different people and yet,
people are writing these individual shows are these handful of actors to be like
the end all be all representatives of diversity.
That's a lot of pressure.
Um,
it's a lot of excitement because diversity suddenly matters right now.
So for me,
the way I'm experiencing it is I'm choosing to look at the positive.
I'm choosing to look at,
um,
these are opportunities and gateways that if this movie does well and it does
matter that this movie does well as controversial.
Some people might be about this is just Chinese people and this is just about
Chinese in Singapore.
Did you read the book?
Like that's what the book's about and you cannot in one singular movie define I
represent all of Asian America,
but still if you,
if this film does well,
it does open up doors for so many other projects to get greenlit and Asians do
have a representation in Hollywood and whether this is true or not.
Yeah,
I don't know if this is an actual fact.
People will say like Asians don't support each other.
They don't watch each other's shows.
If we make a show or a film about Asian people,
the numbers,
like the audience doesn't reflect that.
Right?
So on a numbers in business and industry basis,
diversities in my wheelhouse in my life every single day in terms of not just
authentic storytelling,
but the business of the data points,
the who are the butts in the seats,
how are we showing up?
What kind of viewership are we giving?
Um,
and what does that do right for everybody moving forward in terms of getting
other projects,
other stories told.
Yeah,
well let's,
let's test that right now.
How many of you know,
crazy rich Asians is going to come out?
Okay.
Here's the real test.
How many of you actually have it in your phone that day and you're like already
organizing your friends?
Anybody viewing party?
The point like representation matters,
right?
I think,
I think that's what you're saying.
Yes.
Anything to add?
Well,
I think what's interesting is I think the community support is also really
essential when you're talking about if an Asian American movie comes out.
Um,
and I do understand the,
uh,
the urgent,
the,
the instinct to critique and to be concerned because there has been so little
representation in the past that anything that comes out,
we're so fearful of misrepresentation and more,
uh,
miss assumptions and biases.
Um,
but that support and that dialogue is incredibly important for it to be fostered
and to filter out through the community.
I think the same applies to the literature.
I think the same applies to visual art and to other forms of commit,
you know,
communication and bringing people together through art at to be able to
articulate our experiences.
And so that diversity becomes pretty crucial.
And I agree that diversity happens.
Like the reason why I started writing was I looked around the dinner table at my
family and realize that each of my aunt and uncles and cousins,
and I have my mom and my dad and my grandparents all had a very unique migration
story from Vietnam to America.
All of them,
they had very different experiences.
And that's within a family,
right?
And so there,
there has to be a recognition and appreciation I think,
of that diversity and being able to listen to each other and foster that
communication.
And,
and yet there's still,
this is tension,
right?
This desire to recognize specific and individual experiences with the Asian and
Asian American communities within also,
you know,
we're,
we're all this past month you've been talking about how do we come together,
how do we,
you know,
move forward together.
All right.
So what are some examples in which you've seen?
And I'm thinking of you,
a new bin in particular,
right?
You've seen people negotiate that tension and find a way to build coalitions and
come together.
So storytelling somehow,
it's really important for us with Asian Law Caucus and Tony are client stories
and we're always,
you know,
we talked to thousands and thousands of people every month,
right?
And the question always is like,
which stories do we tell?
Right?
And so for us,
part of that is determining who in our communities,
all his diversity has privileged,
right?
Who has a spotlight,
who has the microphone and who doesn't?
Right?
So we tried to use the privilege that we have,
right?
The spotlight that we have to tell stories that aren't being told.
Um,
and so,
you know,
the stories at dig a told not just in Hollywood but also over social media or
sort of in our communities of,
you know,
his arc committee leaves out a lot of people.
Um,
I often jokingly refer to myself as Asian Asterik,
right?
Um,
because South Asians are often left out of narrative,
who's been,
who's concerned,
Asian,
right?
A Pacific Islanders,
we say Api,
but really no one really thinks about our talks about Pacific islander is most
of the time,
uh,
experience a lot of southeast Asian refugees is also lucked out.
And you've got this very sort of East Asian centric narrative about who is
Asian.
Um,
and so to some degree,
I think,
you know,
we should think about this things when we're thinking about whose stories are we
telling the stories of South Asians and a culture at Ciena,
the quickie mart owner,
the cab driver and the terrorist.
Like those are the three,
you know,
representations we have.
Um,
there's this Muslim ban happening,
but it's not really considered an Asian issue.
So I think in some degree when we talk about building these coalitions,
it's also important to recognize who and are really diverse community has
privilege and to what degree can they sent her.
These other stories are being bused out and help tell those stories inside of
occupying the spotlight with their own stories.
So Russell,
um,
when,
when you're teaching Asian American studies,
you're talking to students about this tension as well.
What are some of the stories that resonate with them about,
um,
the ways Asians and Asian Americans have come together as a coalition to be able
to do things like address injustice or,
um,
you know,
the,
uh,
address,
you know,
maybe not even bad things,
but just come together and coalition.
What are the stories that resonate with students?
Well,
Amy,
of assessment involved in one,
uh,
we,
um,
one of our classes,
I'm Vietnamese American literature,
uh,
did a poetry reading around the me too movement and we found that over half our
class could relate to the issue of domestic violence and abuse on a personnel,
you know,
one degree of separation level.
So there's a lot of concrete issues around which we could build solidarity that
actually totally resonate and um,
and that we can divide up that issue as,
as being a racialized issue as a gendered issue.
And,
um,
when people are able to build,
not only feed their own families affected,
but also developed an empathy to build solidarity with others.
I think that's how we,
that's how my students move.
Hearing each other's stories.
Um,
both knowing the individual uniqueness,
that's story,
but making those connections with others and seeing how race,
how transnationalism,
how capitalism have shaped these experiences to be similar and how we have a
common sort of target of fighting or resisting the suppression.
I think that's what mobile license them.
How does that,
how do you think about,
um,
the representation and then also,
uh,
which stories to tell as you're thinking about,
you know,
the stories that you,
yourself are writing and what you want to share with the audiences.
Well,
my mother was a social worker and she worked with a lot of children who came
over as boat refugees and so,
and she would work on these case files and she,
it was really important for her to express her children that,
to understand the privilege that we came from.
The fact that we came over in the first wave and that we had an education,
we had opportunities that other refugees and immigrants did not have.
And so she was always,
she wasn't a creative writer,
but she would always be showing these stories in order,
like I said,
to increase my compassion and empathy and in gratitude as well.
Like you need to be grateful and what are you going to do with the opportunities
that you have and what stories can you tell.
And so I think a very huge reason why I wanted to become a writer was I wasn't
reading at the time,
there were no Vietnamese American book.
There were very few Asian American books.
The ones you had are burned in my memory.
I still remember a farewell to Manson,
remember?
No,
no boy.
I remember the very few books on my bookshelf that actually reflected my
experience in what I felt like to be someone in a predominantly white
environment.
And when a child especially recognizes him or herself in a book,
it is,
it's a validation.
It's a,
it's a self validation that empowers them.
And I think that is something that literature and art can do in.
And so that's why seeking out those stories,
understanding them.
Like I said,
like with the me too movement,
it was part of a collective call.
She who has no masters,
it's a collective of Vietnamese,
uh,
writers,
women writers and gender nonconforming lighters.
And we want to talk about me too.
And we called it me to Vietnamese bodies.
What are the stories that aren't being told?
Right?
Because me to,
uh,
the me too movement is rooted in social media and not,
there are many people who are not on social media.
How do we collect the stories?
How do we eliminate a lot of that shame?
And it's about listening.
It's about listening and then conveying these stories and talking with each
other.
I mean,
I know for me coming to understand and appreciate my own identity as a Chinese
American in relation to my broader,
you know,
political identity as an Asian American was definitely a process,
right?
To be able to see myself and then two to be able to see myself as part of a
community.
Right.
What was that like for some of you to understand that,
um,
the sense of self identity in connection to this broader identity,
what is something that you want to share?
I think it happened from me at least late and I think it might've been just
because I,
I the the time period,
like I see it happening earlier from my own children.
Like my daughter who's nine strongly identifies as a Vietnamese American,
as a half Vietnamese American from me growing up with a lot of white people
around me.
I didn't feel proud until college,
which is late.
But it was incredibly liberating when it happened because that was when I
started taking the classes.
That's when the Vietnam War wasn't a,
uh,
a taboo word.
That's when there were classes on issues and histories and literature that we're
about the people who look like me.
And now I feel there are more ethnic studies classes happening earlier on
education.
They're more cultural opportunities.
The Vietnamese community has been here for you no longer.
So we have,
and that was the younger generations teaching,
uh,
the children.
And so there are more opportunities when they're younger.
But for me,
it didn't happen until college.
So I grew up in the deep south in New Orleans.
I grew up in a block and Vietnamese neighborhood with very few South Asian
people.
Um,
and so I think I learned early on that I'm not white,
but,
um,
us in terms of coming into like an Asian identity and wasn't exactly clear.
I mean there were way more Vietnamese people then South Asian people in my
neighborhood.
Um,
but I,
I think I definitely learned about race in a much different way.
It is in California.
Uh,
I definitely learned about it in terms of this black white binary that existed
and which side of the line I was on.
Um,
and so I'm still,
I think getting used to being in California and looking around the room like
this is not really exist in the same,
I work at an Oregon was 30 something people.
It's amazing radical Asian lawyers there,
but it's still like mind boggling sometimes.
You know where I am.
Uh,
and it's easy to forget here that agents were only like 5% of the country,
right?
I grew up in San Francisco,
so it was easy growing up in like if you're in an ethnic enclave of 90% Asian
Americans is pretty easy to develop an Asian American consciousness and to um,
tie down up.
So see the patent ethnic commonalities are generational calm.
It was really easy because we are addressing,
I like listening to the same type of music.
I'm playing the same kind of sports,
going to the same clubs.
So that's,
it became a cultural sub or a sub culture that shifted to a political identity
as I began to see.
Um,
yeah,
I'm privileged in some ways as a middle class Asian American,
but there are other Asian Americans who are suffering a lot more people in
Chinatown who aren't getting their wages that I need to,
to support given my privilege.
Um,
I grew up in Cupertino,
uh,
during the 90s and if anyone was growing up in south South Bay and bay area or
la during the 90s,
if you guys remember like the Asian pride era,
you see ADN price special times.
Um,
that's actually when my first film is about.
But,
uh,
that was definitely,
you know,
the post rise at all these academic things about the culture that I don't,
didn't know until really recently.
I just experienced that and like wrote and pride,
all my stuff,
my screen names,
Anga aim,
all that stuff.
So I was very like immersed in that Asian pride culture,
that sub culture.
Um,
and,
but I didn't realize until I moved to Pleasanton
that was special.
It's different now.
But at the time when I moved,
it was still like 97 98% white at the time that I moved in the 90s.
And it was a very stark realization like of being othered and it wasn't hostile
or negative,
but I was definitely singled out and they assigned me to the other Asian girl
too.
You should be friends with Annie.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
And I,
I went with it,
you know,
I was like,
that's my Asian sister.
She's my friend.
It was an automatic connection.
So it was,
it was markers like that that made me very aware of and in a way very prideful
about being Korean American,
being Asian American.
But then navigating that and coming to terms with it really happened again more
towards like the end of high school and college.
Were there cultural organizations where we're talking more.
But even in college I feel like the conversations were not nearly as
sophisticated as now.
We did not have the word intersectionality.
I was,
I ran the Korean American student organization,
we did community service and we partied like that was,
we didn't talk that much about identity.
We didn't really dig into what those dynamics where we will put on culture shows
as a celebration,
but we wouldn't really go in depth.
So I feel like it's been a very ongoing process and enjoining collaboration and
starting the bay area chapter in 2009 was definitely an eye opening experience
to the,
to the wide wider diversity of Asian America.
And I'm continually like,
I feel like now I'm going through Asian American studies.
Like I did,
I wasn't interested in taking those courses when I went to cal.
Um,
and they were available for me.
I just wasn't interested,
which is bizarre.
We won't,
we won't tell your teachers.
Yeah,
please.
So,
um,
you know,
mid,
you started touching about touching on I think,
um,
how things have changed for you over time.
Right?
So I,
you know,
I want to reflect a little bit on that and think about what's,
what is our future,
what is the our community's future look like?
And,
um,
in terms of the diversity,
the identities and our ability to,
what are we working on in terms of coming together?
So,
you know,
what do y'all think is in our future for Asians and Asian Americans?
I,
when we started with collaborations,
I mean,
you've seen so much and to a certain extent the,
the work that you've done in collaboration is also very future future facing,
right?
Absolutely.
Um,
I've been educated more through the people I've met through collaboration
because it was across North America,
including Canada and like understanding how different my upbringing in the bay
area,
my privileged and very diverse upbringing in the bay is very different than
Detroit,
Michigan,
different than Atlanta,
Georgia different than Washington DC.
And so that has been alone,
just its own education.
But what I see in like my peers in,
in the people who support us and the younger generation because of social media,
because of Youtube,
like change the game there is,
there's more conversation happening at a much more rapid pace that's more
sophisticated,
more nuanced.
And therefore I think more just motivational for young kids to learn who they
are,
love who they are and just go out and make amazing things.
They don't have the same level of self consciousness or the same self
limitations that we've all had to navigate for different reasons.
Whether we like our geographical location or the way our parents raised us.
I inherited my 1980 version of Korea from my parents.
You know what I mean?
I didn't grow up with the current Korea.
I go there and I feel like very much other there as much as I'm Korean American,
right?
So we have these very unique stories and I'm just,
the coalitions are real.
I,
you know,
the South Asian community,
everybody,
I honestly think this political climate is,
uh,
you know,
as awful as it is,
it is a blessing in disguise to get people to care and to move.
So they're saying,
okay,
fine,
we're going at this with this like collectively marginalized community,
what do we have to do?
And that's creating a lot of urgency to put aside whatever,
you know,
competitive agendas and all that.
And it's like there is a lot more unity,
a lot more strategy I feel like.
Cause now there's this shared goal of if we don't speak up for ourselves,
if we don't make it a priority to fund get films greenlit,
to make sure to create programs like all the major studios have diversity
programs.
Now this did not exist.
So this creates opportunities for me as an actor that I didn't have that it was
a different playing field five,
10 years ago.
And now they're creating diversity programs where they're,
they're seeking out women of color,
Lgbtq women,
you know,
every one of color,
Lgbtq,
millennials,
they're trying to get different voices in there on purpose because people are
getting pissed off enough and inspired enough to say,
we want to see our communities on screen.
You can't whitewash out of our us out of our own stories and think we're going
to like sit peacefully by and watch this nonsense.
You know what I mean?
So I credit social media.
That's why I'm so proud to be from the bay and to have had my roots in silicon
valley because things that are happening in this place are changing the entire
world.
So I look to that and that is the future and technology and all the platforms
that are emerging.
You are not relegated to like five studios running all of media.
You know,
you have a lot more voices and people are getting scared,
which is
keep them one their tough.
We did jump in with,
Oh yeah,
can I bounce off that?
Um,
so we have more platforms.
We have more opportunities to create voice.
I think emerging Asian Americans will become the creative class of America.
If you look in academia today,
if you look even in the world of literature and arts,
there's a lot of Asian Americans going into it because of selective immigration.
Um,
those coming in today are,
are educated professionals and their kids are becoming the creative class.
And so the creative class or those who create culture who create the discourses
by which we sort of understand the world,
the danger though of Asian Americans becoming the creative class and as I see
this,
sorry to dump on millennials is that,
uh,
please go ahead.
We found them digital prisoners.
Okay,
nice Q and a on everyone's sort of trapped on their own phones and we've come
hyper individualized and so that makes mobilizing on a collective scale a lot
more difficult.
It's easier to do social movements through social media,
but it also divides and conquers us to be market rather than communities.
And so,
um,
as we become the creative class,
Mike,
I think we could redefine what it means to be Asian American.
Nobody thinks of Asian with that.
A history of justice necessarily.
An ethic of compassion.
But as we developed into this creative class,
as long as we could build those commonalities and solidarities and that empathy
and start working,
not just on behalf of our own self interest,
but you know,
out of the concerns were low income people or for other marginalized groups,
then we can actually have possibilities of uh,
to create our identity that we want it to be.
You know,
Asian Americans being adjust people,
Asian Americans being of people equity.
Um,
so for me,
that's the hope that the term and the grouping of Asian American has all this
unforeseen possibility and we can eat and,
and people here are the people who are sort of filling in the gaps of what it
means to be Asian American.
And so that's both exciting.
But Russell A.
Little bit to imprison the buyer phones.
Yeah.
Can we,
I didn't do that.
So I think
we're at a place of crisis and a turning point right now,
but whether or not we take that plunge towards being a community about justice,
um,
so,
you know,
we're the fastest growing community of color in the country.
Never still only like I think five and a half percent.
Um,
and I think the country's in a state of crisis right now,
right?
And there's war happening over white supremacy,
which has been happening in this country for centuries,
right?
But right now it's out in the open.
And so I think the Asian communities at this place where it needs to pick it
sides,
um,
and it's for a really long time and by intention,
we've been used as a weapon against black people,
against people of Color,
right?
Our immigration system is set up,
um,
so that it's only educated Asians that are allowed to easily come to the US,
right?
And so we were always like held up by white supremacy as the good immigrants,
We come here legally,
we're not like a Latina in front set across the border.
We're held up against black people is,
oh,
you know,
there are people of color,
but you know,
they have really high graduation rates and their incarceration rates aren't
high.
Why can't black people be like Asians?
Right?
And that started almost immediately after the civil rights movement was that we
were pitted against other communities of color.
And to a large degree,
we've,
a lot of our communities of times have played into that.
Sometimes that was survival,
you know,
of we're going to try and be respectable and be the good immigrants and it'll
get us as close to whiteness as we can,
right?
There's this hierarchy where we're never quite going to have the rights of white
people open.
Maybe it'll get us close.
And I think there this decision by some communities at certain times to go along
with that because they needed to survive as immigrants in this country.
But in the end it's becoming clearer and clearer that that isn't going to
protect us.
Right?
Uh,
the Muslim ban doesn't care if you're respectable or not.
It doesn't care how a Phd,
um,
it doesn't matter.
Right.
Um,
so I think we're at this juncture if we need to decide about whether we're going
to be silent by white supremacy,
quietly sort of planes and respectability or Castro lot with other communities
of color.
Um,
and I think there's a window that we
now have as community and making these decisions.
Okay.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Um,
I'm very aware that any success I have is due to community organizations.
Like I,
um,
the organization's I credited to become a writer are the Asian American Journal
Association,
the Diaspora of Vietnamese artist network and Asian American studies departments
around the country that helps support my writing and help support my book.
And so I,
it was always built into me that if it wasn't for these people who had been
successful and we're looking to cultivate the younger generations,
I wouldn't have what I had.
And so I think that made me much more appreciative of how important a community
organizations are in terms of influencing generations and allyship.
And that certainly applies to this current political climate.
And I realize that sometimes social media can feel like a bubble.
Like you're only talking to the people who are like you.
But I do see since the election,
more political activism and how are we going to use the resources we have?
Like,
what's,
what superpowers do we have to fight against the things that we're really
concerned about.
And so I see,
you know,
graphic novelist,
a drying and depicting,
uh,
cases of undocumented immigrants,
right?
I see more writing,
I see more editorials,
I see more art.
And these are fostering conversations and helping create dialogues so that,
that threat of,
especially for Asian American munies to look inward and only protect themselves,
can't necessarily happen anymore.
And I think constantly reminding and being reminded of the fact that this
happened to us just 40 years ago,
right?
Just a little over 40 years ago where everything was taken away.
It can happen to any of us.
So what are we going to do?
How are we going to help each other?
And I think reminding ourselves about that allyship and community spaces
important.
Thank you so much.
Um,
I think between,
um,
calling actually like calling us into this discussion about where are we going
to stand,
what are we going to do and how are we going to come together?
I think each of you in your own way,
you know,
talked about that.
So.
All right,
so do your turn.
Now we've heard such rich conversation up here.
I want to make sure that you all have an opportunity to ask questions to engage
with the panelists as well.
If you have a question,
please step up.
There's a migrate here,
right in front of me.
Um,
please do that.
Uh,
so that we can get you on and we can hear you.
Come on baby.
I didn't,
I didn't preset any questions so I don't have any plants in the audience,
so yeah.
Okay.
We have a question right here.
Come on up.
Name is grace.
You,
uh,
Professor Chung had a pet,
some thoughts,
you know,
he had thought the phone was making our generation the hyper individualized and,
and that,
that we needed to move forward.
Uh,
you know,
and,
and that Asian Americans,
hopefully it would be sort of this just community.
So granted that phones aren't going to go away.
Um,
I had a question for you,
Professor John.
Um,
you know,
how can we use the phone?
I mean,
I mean the phone,
I'm an 80 you,
you suggested that,
um,
the phone in in some sense has sort of galvanized and organized folks.
So I guess the question make her everybody is how can we use technology?
It's not going to go away anytime soon and people will have their phones.
How can we use technology in a way that brings together community and,
and,
and to,
um,
moocs,
our community along towards justice?
Great question.
Yeah,
I want to jump in.
So in my work,
uh,
we actually use social media quite a bit to,
organized and it's not by itself.
There's lots of organizing happening on the ground in communities,
but social media is really critical for a lot of the advocacy we do.
Um,
I mean,
I remember,
you know,
Muslim ban 1.0,
that first weekend,
right?
All right.
Um,
were it got signed Friday night and you know,
we started working that very night and then I was blown away by the number of
people that we are able to mobilize and we have not,
we're not able to do that without the Internet.
Right.
Uh,
over standard way of mobilizing for an action is fliers and word of mouth and
that would not have turned out,
you know,
thousands of people at every airport in the country within a few hours.
Right.
Um,
often we run anti-depression campaigns and you were mentioning artists are
really stepping up in,
you know,
helping tell stories through artwork.
Uh,
deeply who's a really amazing graphic novelist,
um,
has been helping us with a lot of our NTT British campaigns and making artwork,
uh,
for unlike petitions which have an enormous amount of impact and getting people
free from detention and also telling their stories.
Um,
we use it to pass legislation.
We do call and actions are all using social media using Facebook and Twitter.
I'm sorry it's hip plug,
Google's competitors.
But it is really a critical thing.
Part of our work.
Now
what do you,
what are you seeing mindgeek in terms of the innovative ways?
Um,
performing artists are using technology.
I think it's been happening organically and with being in a generation that has
grown up in a lot of our formative years and then with a new generation where
they just are born out the womb knowing how to like Hashtag um,
people get savvier by the day.
And I think youtube itself for Asian America period,
everyone credits youtube for changing Asian America because the youtubers,
there's a specific generation specifically between 2006 and 2012 the content
creators,
because we're not inundated with content at that point and there is still early
adopters,
right?
The celebrities that emerged out of that youtube generation still make a living
off of that today.
It created a gateway for Asian Americans to influence a whole other generation
of younger Asian Americans to see themselves.
Because there's a lot of kids out there who will look at youtube as a bigger
deal than like network television.
They can identify their youtube stars,
they cannot identify,
you know,
Jimmy Fallon or whoever.
Right?
And so it's just really interesting because that gave people confidence and it
makes that ripple effect.
I really believe in the power of art.
Like a book of song or a Skit,
like it's so random,
but it really gives a kid or an older whoever,
whoever watches it,
they're like,
oh,
they get me,
they get my story.
Oh.
And then they start messaging each other.
They share it like the sharing of videos and there's tweeting and all that.
It has massive ripple effects.
You don't know what kinds of seeds that plants.
Right.
And um,
so I think the Internet is incredibly powerful.
It can galvanize people,
it motivates people.
It pisses people off because they're like,
oh,
you made that skip.
But that was funny.
But it was at the expense of these people right there.
I've seen these conversations happen where like young Asian American kids would
kind of make a gay joke and then that would cause a whole conversation about the
issues within the Asian American community about not acknowledging the Lgbtq
community.
Right.
And so then someone would go out and make their own skit to like re,
you know,
that's kind of the age that we live in.
There's tons of content out there,
but I think that that's what needs to happen.
It's not just theory and our thoughts we've got to do and we got to say we got
to speak and that's going to keep maturing the conversation.
That's what's going to make content creators get better at what they do.
Like I can sit here and say I'm a writer,
but if I never put words on a piece of paper on a s,
you know,
type it out,
I'll never get better.
And I think that's a lot of the things that I've seen in Asian America is like
that self limitation,
this fear of rocking the boat,
this fear of like shaming our families.
I can't air my family's dirty laundry cause all our stories are so personal and
very deep.
Um,
but if we don't do that,
then we come,
we're just going to stay invisible.
You know what I mean?
So that like if you're,
if you're a generation of kids and you can actually say,
I don't like the scarlet Johannson casting,
that's great.
Like the world needs to know that.
And then Hollywood reporter can write an editorial on that about the problematic
nature of whitewashing and they'll bring up Mickey Rooney.
They'll bring up everything,
you know,
Bruce Lee and clean everything and then we can start having those conversations.
So sharing I believe in every individual and here just cause you're not an actor
or writer or a theory or producer,
whatever.
Everyone through their power,
their phone has the power of influence those dates.
Somebody is looking at that data.
Somebody who's making decisions based off of that,
right?
Like viewership.
There are artists that are independent that make their living off of youtube
viewership and get hired to speak at colleges or like do a little music.
They make their living off of that.
So those views,
I know for a fact count so much.
So I I like don't ever like take yourself out of the running of your own
influence.
Russell.
Amy,
quick last thoughts.
You have a lot of thoughts.
Technology isn't necessarily organic and the development,
it's capitalized and it's funded and people are making money off of technology.
And I would argue that technology has become the opiate of the masses,
that Asian Americans are so concerned about their representation and how they
are seen and whether we're invisible or who does what to who.
I see my family every day.
I see you.
I know them by name visible to me.
I know there's,
sorry they don't have to tell me their story.
They're not the voiceless.
So,
but we're still concerned about representation,
but we're not concerned about repo real people living in real conditions.
And so it's both.
And it is that our representations need to affect how we care about people and
their material conditions.
Are they poor?
Do they have health care access to Kelly's speak to a doctor in their language.
So I'm sort of concerned that for Asian Americans who are so concerned about
representation,
they got to get out side of technology and start dealing with real people in
real situations and develop a sense of compassion and heart to.
So it's not just about telling a story,
it's about alleviating the injustices and the poverty.
And the struggle is that a lot of people are going through it.
Now a lot of Asian Americans who look like you and me,
if you're Asian American who could be like your grandparents are going through
really hard difficulties.
And if all we care about this representation,
I think they're just like,
oh,
I'm going to just watch another youtube video to de stress.
Right?
Social media is causing,
Asian Americans have higher rates of anxiety and depression now in this
generation than ever before.
So it has its good things,
but we have to be aware
that's also a residual from actual Asia.
I mean,
Koreans have the highest rate of suicide in the world and alcoholism and plastic
surgery.
And like that's a documentary I would like to make to talk about.
They don't want to talk about it though.
So like I,
I completed that.
I am learning so much.
Um,
I really want to talk to you
and it was this,
this is great though,
but because I feel like there's just this difference because the people that I'm
around,
the artists that I'm around particular,
they care about everything about that.
So there's,
there's always going to be pockets and different arrange of people who care.
I'm just like a beauty blogger just to send me all the sponsored products and
that's all they care about.
Fine,
but they have influence on like when they start talking about body image and
anxiety and like dysmorphia,
Anorexia,
like eating disorders,
whatever and then you can have the people who are very socially social justice
minded because when they see that only the things that people are talking about
are things about looking pretty and your Instagram filter there,
it's going to,
it's going to cause a rise out of people who like what about refugees?
What about poverty?
And they'll get motivated to make those stories shine too.
I mean there's tensions,
right?
Amy,
you have the last word.
Well I think it's the content in social media that is making us anxious.
Like I,
I,
there is a lot of noise but I think people can also become really good about
listening to what's important.
A lot of those stories,
we wouldn't know about them if they were not social media.
And I do think the reason why representation is important,
it becomes a gateway.
Like those stories are important for us to feel.
Most people are feel,
uh,
they are motivated by their emotions rather than by facts.
Like I didn't really understand or I didn't really feel the impact of so many
historical events until I read about it,
about even fictional characters,
experiencing that emotion,
going through these feelings of shame or anger or frustration or alienation.
And that is how we create compassionate with other people.
And that's how other people learn our stories and then they try to make a
difference.
But if we don't have those stories available,
then we're not going to have people curious to be able to hear more and listen
and pay attention to the very real issues of the fact that there is an
incredible diversity in Asian Americans in that we have,
uh,
we have the opportunities to help each other to help all income levels of Asian
Americans and see where we're coming from and where are we supposed to go?
Well,
I want to thank
each of you,
Amy,
a Noob Russel mangy for contributing to a really,
really rich conversation.
Um,
Kelly say thank you to them.
[inaudible].